ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET TO
ORDER- WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
MISS ERIKA LEAVE WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
PRESENT ALL THE BILLS
AFTERWARDS WE WILL GO TO MR
PADDOCK R. L. A. O. OF TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS IF YOU CHOOSE TO
DO SO WE'RE JUST. TAKING THE
QUESTIONS- WE WILL THEN TAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
THERE IS NO VOTE IN COMMITTEE
TODAY. THAT WHEN WE RETURN TO
THE FLOOR WE WILL TAKE OF THESE
BILLS AS WELL AS S. B. ONE FIVE
NINE- WHICH IS SB ONE FIVE
NINE. THEN LET ME JUST TURN
OVER TO MR FAULTY BUSINESS
COMMENTS OKAY WE WILL START
WITH- MISLEAD WHO WILL. YES
THIS IS THE TV ON HELLO. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
EXCELLENT THANK YOU OKAY FOR
HER VOICE STRAINED HAVEN'T. FOR
FIGURE. SHE'S ONE OF THE- AB
ONE THIRTY THREE ON THE FIRST
TRAILER BILL OF THE TWELVE THAT
WILL BE HEARD THEY ADOPT THE
HEALTH- INVEST THIS BILL
EXPANDS FULL SCOPE MEDICAL
BENEFITS TO PERSONS FIFTY YEARS
AND OLDER NO SOONER THAN MAY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IT
EXTENDS TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY
IS ALLOWED DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THROUGH
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
INCLUDING PAYMENT PARITY FOR
SERVICES DELIVERED THROUGH
AUDIO ON THE MODALITIES.
ELIMINATE FROM ASSET TEST WHICH
APPLIES TO OLDER ADULTS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. IF
YOU WANT THIRTY THREE
IMPLEMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING A
MEDIC CAL OR CAL AIM
INITIATIVE. A MULTI YEAR WEAVER
INITIATIVE TO PROVIDE A WIDER
ARRAY OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FOR PATIENTS WITH COMPLEX AND
HIGH NEEDS. IT ALSO EXTENDS THE
MEDI CAL POSTPARTUM CARE PERIOD
FROM SIXTY DAYS TO TWELVE
MONTHS. WITHOUT REQUIRING A
MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS ON
ABOUT OF THE SCOPE OF COVERED
SERVICES FOR A FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
IT ALSO EXTENDS DENTAL MANAGED
CARE CONTRACTS FOR SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTIES
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND AB
ONE THIRTY THREE AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
TO REQUIRE INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL PATIENTS. SEEM TO BE
UNDER STARBUCKS MENTAL
COMPETENCY TO BE RETURNED TO
THE COUNTY WITHIN TEN DAYS AND
REMAIN IN THE COUNTY OTHERWISE
THE DEPARTMENT WILL CHARGE A
COUNTY A DAILY BED RATE FOR THE
CONTINUE TREATMENT. AND
ADDITIONALLY SB ONE THIRTY
THREE AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS. RIGHT NOW
WITH LOCAL COUNTY JAIL TO
REEVALUATE INDIVIDUALS DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON A
FELONY CHARGE YOU HAVE WAITED
IN JAIL SIXTY DAYS OR MORE.
PENDING PLACEMENT TO THE STATE
HOSPITAL TREATMENT PROGRAM.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT ITEMS CURRENTLY
CONTAINED IN AB ONE THIRTY
THREE- THE ADMINISTRATION.
CONTINUES TO WORK AT THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAFF TO CLOSE
OUT A HANDFUL OF OTHER PRIORITY
ISSUES WITH THE GOAL OF
INCLUDING PARENTS AS WELL AND
AN OMINOUS I'LL FELL. I'M
THINKING AHEAD HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS ARE **** SHELLING
CONTINUE THROUGH THE REST OF
THE BILLS- MISTER TECH. WELL
YOU JUST KEEP GOING THROUGH IN
THE LOGISTICAL QUESTIONS
TOGETHER. OKAY SOUNDS GOOD
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO AB SB
ONE PRETTY FAR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT- THIS BILL MAKES
AN APPROPRIATION OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX POINT NINETY SEVEN
BILLION FROM THE FEDERAL TRUST
FUND TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IT EXTEND
AUTHORIZATION TO THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR BUT
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO ALLOW PARENTS
TO DETERMINE THE PERCENTAGE OF
FINES. TO ALLOCATE ACROSS
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS BY
MEANS OF ALL COUNTY LETTERS. OR
OTHER SIMILAR INSTRUCTIONS
WITHOUT TAKING FOR THE
REGULATORY ACTION. AND IT
AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY THAT IS
UNABLE TO SUBMIT A PLAN OR
ANNUAL UPDATE FOR THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. DUE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY TO EXTEND THE
EFFECTIVE TIME FRAME OF ITS
CURRENTLY APPROVED PLAN. FOR
ANNUAL UPDATE AND THEN SUBMIT A
PLAN TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BY JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. MOVING ON TO A. B.
S. B. ONE THIRTY SIX
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. THIS
BILL OUTLINES A MULTI YOUR
SERVICE PROVIDER RATE INCREASE
BASED ON THE TWENTY NINETEEN
RATE STUDY INCREASING RATES BY
ONE POINT TWO. BILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX WITH AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING CONSUMER OUTCOMES AND
QUALITY OF SERVICES. IT
REQUIRES AN APARTMENT AT
CONVENE A WORKGROUP TO IDENTIFY
AND DEVELOP STANDARD
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENTS
INDICATORS AND BENCHMARKS TO
INCENTIVIZE HIGHER QUALITY
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS. IT
ALSO DEVELOPS A CAREER PATH FOR
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
DELIBERATION OF A WORK FORCE OF
A WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENTAL PROGRAM TIED TO
TIERED WAGES THAT PROMOTES
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES THAT
ARE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY SENSITIVE. THE
BILL ALSO PRIORITIZES SERVICE
ACCESS AND EQUITY THROUGH A
NUMBER OF NEW INITIATIVES- AND
LASTLY PROVIDES PROVISIONAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AGED
THREE AND FOUR IF THEY EXHIBIT
SIGNIFICANT FUNCTIONALITY
FUNCTIONAL LIMITATIONS REDUCING
THE LIKELIHOOD OF CHILDREN WERE
TRYING TO REACH OUT CENTERS.
AFTER EXITING EARLY STARTS. OF
MOVING ON TO AB SP ONE THIRTY
SEVEN- THAT STATE GOVERNMENT.
AB ONE SEVEN AMENDS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SCHOOL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM TO ADD AS AN
ELIGIBLE ENTITY A REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER THAT IS
OPERATED BY A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY AND THAT HAS AN
ACTIVE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN PROVIDES A
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO INSPECT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW MULTI
FAMILY AND SINGLE FAMILY MARKET
RATE RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS AS
ALL ELECTRIC BUILDINGS OR WITH
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS. THE
BILL ADDRESSES EIGHT COUNTY
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD
DEADLINE- GROUP. PROVIDES
COUNTY ASSESSMENT APPEALS
BOARDS TWO YEARS TO HEAR
APPEALS FROM PROPERTY OWNERS
CHALLENGING THEIR PROPERTY'S
ASSESSED VALUE. THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN EXTENSION UNTIL
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR FOR ALL COUNTY ASSESSMENT
APPEALS THAT HIT THE TO YOUR
DEADLINE BETWEEN MARCH FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY AND DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST OF THIS YEAR- AB
SB ONE THREE SEVEN SPECIFIES
THE ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
IN MANAGING THE STATE'S
INCORRECT. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
ELEMENTS- GOVERNMENT CODE TO
REMOVE LANGUAGE FOR DEPARTMENTS
TO REIMBURSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY FOR INFORMATION
SECURITY AUDITS AUDITS WILL
INSTEAD BE FUNDED THROUGH
GENERAL FUND. BEGINNING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- ALLOW FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO CONTRACT FOR THE USE OF A
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD
PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD FOR NO
MORE THAN THREE STATE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS- AND FINALLY
THE MEN'S BY CLEANING
CALIFORNIA ACT WHICH WAS
ENACTED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TO
TARGET CARBON EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MANUFACTURING OF MATERIALS USED
IN PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS- BUT
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT BILL AB
SP ONE THIRTY EIGHT THE-
EMPLOYMENT AND HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS. TRAILER BILL- AB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT AB ACTUALLY OE
THIRTY EIGHT REQUIRES THE-
WOMEN DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
EDT TO OFFER UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM SERVICES AND
THE TOP EIGHT TO FIFTEEN
ADDITIONAL ARE NON PRIMARY
LANGUAGES USED BY- LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA. ALSO REQUIRES EACH
PROVIDE A FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION PLAN ASSESSING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION TOOLS
BY NINETY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
BUDGET BY JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. UP WITH AN UPDATE
ON DVDS PROGRESS PERFORMING
THAT ASSESSMENT. IT REQUIRES
EIGHTY TO PROVIDE A DIRECT
DEPOSIT OPTION FOR ITS BENEFIT
PROGRAMS IN ADDITION TO THE
OPTIONS CURRENTLY PROVIDED SUCH
AS DEBIT CARDS AND PAPER
CHECKS- THE BILL ALSO EXTENDS
THE INCREASED. US STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE R. STI
WAIT REPLACEMENT RATE ENACTED
BY EIGHTY NINE OH EIGHT. FROM
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- MAYBE SB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT AMEND SOME PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES MEDICAL AND HOSPITAL
CARE ACT DEPENDENT ELIGIBILITY.
VERIFICATION IT ALSO
APPROPRIATES ONE POINT EIGHT
EIGHT BILLION ONE TIME PROP TO
THAT REPAYMENT FUNDING TO
FURTHER REDUCE THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES. OTHER CALPERS
STATE PLANS. AND BY LATE
APPROPRIATE SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
ON BEHALF OF EMPLOYEES FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EMPLOYEE
PRETENDING CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
WERE SUSPENDED. PURSUANT TO
THAT TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
ARE MOVING ON TO AB SB ONE
FORTY ONE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS- SOME NOTABLE
HIGHLIGHTS ARE THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES.
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION- SPECIAL FUNDS AND
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
POSITIONS TO CONSOLIDATE THE
FUNCTIONS AND POSITIONS. OF THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH INTO A NEW
STAND ALONE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL WITHIN THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY BEGINNING. TODAY
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GOAL OF THIS NEW DEPARTMENT IS
TO SIMPLIFY PARTICIPATION IN
THE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET AND
SUPPORT THE SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE
OPERATION OF CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW. AB AT THE ONE FORTY
ONE REFLECTS THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT TO ACTUATE THE
CONSOLIDATION OF POSITIONS AND
LICENSING. LICENSING FUNCTIONS
OF THE BILL INCLUDES COMPONENTS
THAT ADDRESS PROVISIONAL
LICENSE HIGH WINDS MERGES THE
REGULATION AUTHORITY
TRANSSEXUALS. AMONG OTHER
ISSUES. UP MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT TRAILER BILL AB ONE FORTY
THREE AB SB ONE FORTY THREE AND
COURTS- THIS BILL EXPANDS
ONLINE THE ABILITY TO PAY PILOT
PROGRAM FROM THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT STATEWIDE
FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS TO
APPLY ONLINE. TIMBRE FINES AND
FEES FOR TRAFFIC AND NON
TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS REDUCED BY
AT LEAST FIFTY PERCENT. OF IT
ALLOWS ALL COURT USERS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME TO
EDUCATE TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS ONLINE. AB S. B.
ONE FORTY THREE- COMBINES THE
IMMEDIATE AND CRITICAL NEED TO
COUNT ON THE STATE COURT
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUND
WHICH ARE THE PRIMARY. FUNDING
SOURCES FOR THE JET JUDICIAL
BRANCH FACILITIES PROGRAM THIS
WILL ALLOW THE STATE PARK
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION BY
JERMAINE SOLVENT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND PROMOTES EFFICIENCY
FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH- THE
BILL PROVIDES THE FUNDING
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY TO BACK
FILL COUNTIES FOR LOST
REVENUES. FROM THE ELIMINATION
OF SOME FINE AND BE TYPES FOR
SEVEN TO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE.
AND IT THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO UTILIZE THE
DESIGN BUILD METHODOLOGY FOR
FUTURE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
SIMILAR TO OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS SPECIFICALLY THIS
LANGUAGE WILL MAKE THE EXISTING
PILOT PROGRAM. A PERMANENT
OPTION FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
ARE MOVING ON TO AB SB ONE
FORTY FIVE- THE TRAILER BILL
AND PUBLIC SAFETY. THIS BILL
PROVIDES AUTOMATIC ARREST
RECORD RELIEF FOR CERTAIN
NONVIOLENT CRIMES DATING BACK
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. AND
EXPENSE THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS FROM SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE COMMISSIONERS
CREATES A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
PLACEMENT OF LOCAL JUSTICE
INVOLVED JUVENILE WORKS. AT
PINE GROVE YOU CAN CONSERVATION
CAMP TO PROVIDE THEM WITH JOB
TRAINING AND RE ENTRY
OPPORTUNITIES. WELL ESTABLISHES
A COUNTY RESENTENCING I LIVE
PROGRAM TO FUND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICES. TO PETITION FOR
REQUEST FOR RESENTENCING. BUT I
THAT THE READY FOR BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
REPRESENTATIVES TO MAKE
UNANNOUNCED JAIL INSPECTIONS
UNLESS EXPANDS THE ALLOWABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR REIMBURSEMENT
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMINATIONS- AND THEN EXPEL IS
AB SB ONE FORTY NINE ON
TRANSPORTATION. OF AB SB ONE
FOR NINE EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DATE FOR CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION ACT OR
NEPA DELEGATION FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS FROM TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT
PROVIDES OR EXTEND STATUTORY
RELIEF TO TRANSIT AGENCIES
IMPACTED BY THE GROUP IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT INCLUDES
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE FOR THE
CLEAN CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE-
CLEAN CALIFORNIA WILL ENHANCE
CALTRANS LITTER REMOVAL
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS THAT CAUSE
LETTER. AB SB ONE FORTY NINE
EXTENDS FROM. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THE 10% CAP THAT
CALTRANS CAN CHARGE SELF HELP
COUNTIES FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
PORTION OF ITS INDIRECT COST
RECOVERY CHARGES. AB ONE AB SB
ONE FORTY NINE PROVIDES CITIES
AND COUNTIES. TEMPORARY RELIEF
FROM MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENTS IN THE SB ONE
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
PROGRAM- AND THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR THE DMV EIGHT TO
DEVELOP A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
MOBILE DRIVER'S LICENSE. I'M
MOVING ON TO AB ONE FIFTY A. B.
S. B. ONE FIFTY SALES AND USE
TAX PERSONAL INCOME TAX
CORPORATION TAX LAW- THIS BILL
CONTAINS MOST OF THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT ARE PART OF THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT INCLUDING. THE MAIN
STREET TO HIRING CREDIT
EXPENSIVE CREDIT BY ALLOCATING
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
MILLION TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
BUSINESSES BUT UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. THAT SHOWED
A YEAR OVER YEAR DROP OF AT
LEAST 20% IN GROSS RECEIPTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY- THE HOMELESS
HIRING CREDIT ALLOCATES THIRTY
MILLION PER YEAR FOR A TAX
CREDIT FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
WITH PAY AT LEAST ONE HUNDRED.
20% OF THE MINIMUM WAGE. KALKA
BEATS EXPANSION INCREASES THE
ANNUAL CAT CAL COMPETES
ALLOCATION BY ONE HUNDRED TEN
MILLION TO TWO HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION. A ONE TIME BASIS AND
BUDGET YEAR. ELECTED PASTOR
ENTITY TAX AND ALLOW CERTAIN-
BUSINESS OWNERS TO MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF FEDERAL TAX
LEGISLATION ENACTED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THAT CAPS THE AMOUNT
OF STATE AND LOCAL TAXES CAN BE
DEDUCTED FROM FEDERAL INCOME
TAX RETURNS AT TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. OF DIAPERS AND
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS SALES TAX
EXEMPTION PERMANENTLY EXTENDS A
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR DIAPERS
AND MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. AND
ELIMINATES WROTE RELATED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS- AND
FRESH FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
CREDIT EXPENSE FOR FIVE YEARS A
TAX CREDIT EQUAL 215% OF THE
VALUE OF FRESH FRUITS OR
VEGETABLES. DONATED TO A FOOD
BANK. OKAY MOVING ON TO AB SB
ONE FIFTY ONE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THIS BILL- CREATES
THE CAL COMPETES GRANT PROGRAMS
PROVIDE GRANTS TO BUSINESSES
THAT MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA- THE
BUDGET INCLUDES THIRTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND
TO PROVIDE MICROGRAMS UP TO
ONE. UP TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
DIRECTLY TO ELIGIBLE START UPS
TO SEATED. ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
SMALL BUSINESS CREATION AND
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESS
GROUPS THAT ARE FACING CAPITAL
AND OPPORTUNITY GAPS. IT IS
AMBITIOUS CALIFORNIA VENUES
GRANT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL GROUP BELIEVED
INDEPENDENT ENUES LIVE EVENT
BUSINESSES AND MINOR LEAGUE
SPORTS. IT IS CHALLENGES THE
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE. TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS ORGANIZATIONS.
AT IT IS NOT WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA MY PER BUSINESS-
COMING NINETEEN REALLY GRANT
PROGRAM WITHIN THE CALIPHATE'S
HELP. OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE. TO THIS
QUALIFIED MICRO BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN NEGATIVELY AFFECTED
BY THE COMING NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
I'M LASTLY. MOVING OUT. AB
FIFTY SEVEN THE CRIME FOR
PREVENTION- TELL ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM IF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AS AN ENTITY ADMINISTERING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CIRCUIT
PROSECUTOR GRANT PROGRAMS AND
AS AN ANSI RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT EDUCATION- IT IS
ABLUTIONS SORRY IN ESTABLISHES
A GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONAGENCY AND
AUTHORIZES COUNTY PA TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO QUALIFY GRANTEES TO
ADMINISTER ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT. EDUCATION TRAINING.
AND WITH THAT I BELIEVE THAT
WAS ALL THE WEALTH OF THE
TRAILERBILLS AND THOSE WERE-
HIGHLIGHTS- NOT EVERYTHING THAT
WAS INCLUDED BUT I'M HERE WITH
MY TEAM AND HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISLI-
MISTER PETTIT DID YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ARE YOU HERE JUST FOR
QUESTIONS. YES GOOD MORNING-
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS- I WE DON'T. AGAIN
PATRICK FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY- PREPARED REMARKS BUT I'M
HERE WITH. MEMBERS OF OUR
OFFICE- IN WERE AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS. MR
FONG THE WITH DOCTOR TOWARD. I
THINK IT WAS I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME- I
JUST A FEW QUESTIONS WERE JUST
UP FROM BILL THE BILL IF YOU
DON'T MIND AS BARBARA FINANCE
R. S. B. ONE THIRTY FOUR- THE
BILL APPROPRIATES AT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION. OF A
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- WHAT IS THE PLAN A
PROCESS- TO CONTINUE OR TO RE
EVALUATE. ONCE THEM ONE TIME
MONEY IS EXHAUSTED. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE HEALTH MINISTER. WE ARE
ALMOST A PERMANENT FINANCE. SO
THE PLAN TO REEVALUATE THE-
WOULD BE WITH CONTINUED FEDERAL
FUNDING. THE FUNDING THAT IS
INCLUDED AND AB ONE THIRTY FOUR
IS A ONE TIME SUPPLEMENTAL
FEDERAL FUNDS. ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE ONGOING. FEDERAL FUNDS
SO ANY- SORT OF WORK THAT IT
DOES TO STOP LARGE AND INOUR
CONTINUE COULD BE RETALIATED
WITH THOSE RESOURCES. OKAY IS
THERE AN INDICATION THAT THAT
THE FEDERAL FUNDS WOULD
CONTINUE BECAUSE IT WOULD OR IS
THIS ARE THESE FEDERAL FUNDS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE COVERT
RELIEF- FUNDS. THE FEDERAL
FUNDS AND AB ONE THIRTY FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL TO THE- REGULARLY
APPROPRIATED FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOWEVER THE
STANDARD FUNDING THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES FOR
A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WOULD
CONTINUE OKAY- I THANK YOU FOR
THAT- JUMPING TO- TO SB ONE
THIRTY SEVEN- THIS BILL CREATES
SEVERAL NEW PROGRAMS HOW MANY
POSITIONS ARE BEING CREATED
AND- IN. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED AT
THE GENERAL FUND SO WHAT IS THE
STRATEGY THE FUND- THESE
PROGRAMS AFTER THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION MR FONG
SO THAT EIGHT EIGHT ABA SP ONE
THIRTY SEVEN I BELIEVE THAT'S
THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT BILL
YOU'RE SPEAKING UP. ACTUALLY
HAS MANY. THERE ARE MANY
DEPARTMENTS- IN THIS- INCLUDED
IN THIS TRAILERBILL SO I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENT IN MIND OR JUST
SPECIFIC PROGRAM- I. MAYBE YOU
CAN JUST GIVE IS IT DO YOU HAVE
A GENERAL- ACCOUNTING OF HOW
MANY PROGRAM PROGRAMS THIS BILL
CREATES- IT NO THAT'S IT- NOT
REALLY- POSSIBLE TO IT AT THIS
POINT WITH THIS TRAILER BILL I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF-
BCPS ARE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS THAT- WOULD. LIKELY
BE INCLUDED INCLUDED UNDER THE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT- SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD LOOK AT
GENERALLY BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDE INCLUSIVE
IT IN THIS TRAILER BILL OKAY
WELL MAYBE SPECIFICALLY THE
PROPOSED ENERGY UNIT. HOW MANY
POSITIONS ARE IN THAT. OKAY YES
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN SPEAK TO- IN
REGARDS TO THE NEW ENERGY AND I
AGAIN I BELIEVE YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT THE ENERGY UNIT THAT'S
MOVING FROM THE PC YES TO THOSE
OKAY- JUST ONE MOMENT. IS
ANYBODY ON THE LINE FROM HEY
GOOD MORNING AND WEBER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
ANY INTERVIEW THAT'S GOING TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IS FOR FIVE
POSITIONS ON GOING. AND IT'S A
GENERAL FUND COSTS ON GOING
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET. OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN- THE BILL
REQUIRES THE SEC TO ADMINISTER-
A STATEWIDE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FOR THE- FOR ALL ELECTRIC MULTI
FAMILY AND SINGLE FAMILY
BUILDINGS- IS A BADASS IS DONE
ON THE- THE AVERAGE COST.
ENERGY COSTS TO HOMEOWNERS IF.
OF AN ALL ELECTRIC HOME. OR
BUSINESS VERSUS SAY A HOME OR
BUSINESS TO OPERATE WITH
NATURAL GAS CONNECTIONS. CAN I
TURN THAT QUESTION OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE DAMIEN I'M NOT. YES
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- I DON'T BELIEVE I
HAVE THAT SPECIFIC INFORMATION
WITH ME BUT I WILL CERTAINLY-
WORK WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO GET YOU THAT INFORMATION AND
TO BE CLEAR THIS BECAUSE THE
AVERAGE. COST OF AN ELECTRIC
HOME VERSUS A HOME WITH- OTHER
APPLIANCES. YEAH THE AVERAGE
ENERGY COSTS FOR AN ALTAR CALL
MORE BUSINESS VERSES THE SAME-
HOME OR BUSINESS THAT WOULD
OPERATE WITH NATURAL GAS
CONNECTION. WITH THAT WHAT
WOULD THAT ANALYSIS GO INTO-
ANY- OF ANY YOU KNOW GUIDELINES
THAT THE CDC DEVELOPS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT REQUIRE RIGHT
YES THE BILL OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
YES THAT IS CORRECT- THE
TRAILER BILL ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS AUGMENTATION DOES REQURE
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO-
DEVELOP TIME LINES- BY THE END
OF FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE DASH TWENTY TWO- I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT THE-
GUIDELINES BUT- INCLUDE THAT
ASSESSMENT BUT AGAIN I WILL GO
BACK AND CHECK WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND SEVEN
CORRECTION TO YOUR OFFICE. I
APPRECIATE THAT- GOING TO S. S.
B. AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT- THIS
MEASURE I UNDERSTAND IT CREATES
ABOUT A NEW GOVERNMENT PILOT
PROGRAM THAT THAT FUNDS
QUALIFIED ORGANIZATIONS WITH
QUOTE A MINIMUM OF FIVE YEARS
EXPERIENCE- OBTAINING WAGE
CLAIMS AGAINST PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS- I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS. WHY NOT USE EXISTING STATE
STAFF FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IF THE ATTENTION
IS ABOUT ENFORCEMENT VERSUS-
VERSUS FUNDING. TO FILE WAGE
CLAIMS AGAINST PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS. ALTERNET QUESTION TO
MY COLLEAGUE DANIEL BRANDON. HI
GOOD MORNING DANIEL BRANDED THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M WITH
REGARD TO THIS TRAILER BILL
THAT THE- THE FUNDING IS AIMED
TO GO TOWARDS- A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT WILL
PROVIDE EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS AND
WORK WITH THEM AT TO FILE
CLAIMS ON THIS RELATIONSHIP IS
NECESSARY- GIVEN BE AT TARGET
POPULATION- YES AND THEN THEY
WOULD WORK WITH STATE STAFF OF
THE CLAIM NEEDED TO BE FILED.
SO WHAT WOULD- SO WHAT IS A
CALL IT WHAT WHAT IT WHAT WOULD
BE A QUALIFIED ORGANIZATION
COULD YOU GIVE AN EXAMPLE. OF.
ONE I'M SURE THERE ARE
COMMUNITY CENTERS- COMMUNITY
CENTERS CHURCHES ARE EXAMPLES-
I CAN GET A LITTLE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LIST FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND HAVE THAT SENT
OVER. SURE YOU KNOW THAT THAT
WOULD BE- THAT WE HAVE WHY I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF
WHAT TYPE OF ORGANIZATION-
WOULD RECEIVE- THESE TAX
DOLLARS- BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
CHURCH IS. THE CHURCH IS NOT
BASED. GO OUTSIDE AND MAJOR AND
DROPPED. NO I DIDN'T INTERRUPT
YOU I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR. SO
USING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT'S A
RELATIVELY BROAD IS THERE LIKE
A SPECIFIC ORGANIZATION THAT'S
LIKE MODELED OFF OF LIKE. THESE
TYPES OF THAT THAT DO THESE
TYPES OF- WHICH CLAIMS. THERE
ARE MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS- HI
I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
WITH THE SPECIFIC TYPES. OKAY
THAT THAT'LL BE HELPFUL- TWO S.
B. ONE FORTY THREE OR EIGHTY
ONE FORTY THREE- WHAT IS THE
CURRENT FUND STATUS OF THE-
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND- AS WELL AS
THE IMMEDIATE AND CRITICAL
NEEDS ACCOUNT- AS I UNDERSTAND
IT AND LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
BOTH ARE CRITICALLY LOW AND AT
RISK OF INSOLVENCY- SO HOW WE
COMBINING THE TWO FUNDS-
ADDRESS THAT PREVENT
INSOLVENCY- OR IS THERE NEEDED
REFORMS THAT HAVE TO BE
ASSOCIATE WITH THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION I'LL URN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
LINE FOR THE PARKS. A GOOD
MORNING JESSE LEVINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO AS IT STANDS
CURRENTLY THE STATE COURT
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUNDING
ISN'T WILL BE SOLVENT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. ANY IMMEDIATE
CRITICAL NEEDS ACCOUNT HAS. A
POSITIVE FUND BALANCE- WHICH IF
WE COMBINE THE MEETING CRITICAL
NEEDS ACCOUNT WITH THE STATE OR
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUND.
IT WILL ALLOW THE DP TO REMAIN
SOLVENT IN THE BUDGET YEAR IN
OUR GOAL WITH THE FARM
CONSOLIDATION. WAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE ALLOW FOR THE SPECIAL
FUNDS TO REMAIN SOLVENT WITHOUT
PUTTING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES ON THERE- I COULD I
COULD REACH OUT TO YOUR OFFICE
OFFERING TO PROVIDE YOU THE
EXACT FIGURES. ON THE BALANCE
OF THE MEETING CRITICAL IN THE
COUNT WHICH DOES HAVE A
POSITIVE FUND BALANCE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. OKAY SO THIS IS
THE SO I UNDERSTAND SAID THE
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION PLAN IT WOULD GO
INSOLVENT. IN THIS UPCOMING
BUDGET YEAR. SO THE WAY.
JUDGING I DON'T KNOW S. B. BUT
WHERE IS YOUR MOUTH BUT IT
SOUNDS THAT YOU'RE- INFUSING.
THE STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND WITH. THE
FUNDS. IN THE IMMEDIATE
CRITICAL NEED TO COUNT. YES
CITY MEDIA CRITICAL NEED
ACCOUNT IS A CELL CAL AT THE
STATE OFFICER CAN. FUND SO THE
GOAL HERE IS REALLY TO KIND
THIS OUT ACCOUNT. INTO THE NEW
LAW STATE COURT FACILITY AND
SHOT FUND IS REALLY OF THE ON.
ON FOR OKAY ON THAT SIDE COULD
SHUT ISSUES FOR IS THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH- IS THAT SACRIFICING ANY
OF THE PRICE. WITHIN THE ARMY
CRITICAL NEED TO CAL. OR OKAY
YEAH OKAY SO A COUPLE. THERE
THAT WOULD ELEVEN. OKAY I AND
THEN LASTLY ON A ONE NINE-
ADDITIONAL DRIVERS AND. GRAHAM
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE CHALLENGES
THE DMB HAS HAD- IN THE PAST-
AND MAYBE UP TO NOW AS WELL-
WHAT IS ITS CURRENT CAPACITY IN
TERMS OF TAKING ON THIS
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD AND DO THEY
HAVE THAT CAPACITY OR- OR
EXPERTISE- IF YOU COULD. SHED
SOME LIGHT ON THAT. SURE I'LL
TURN THAT QUESTION TO MY
COLLEAGUE DAMIAN AND NOW. GOOD
MORNING YES I'M JIM TAKE ON-
THIS PROJECT. THEY HAVE- THAT
WORKS TO- DEVELOPING THEN
SHARED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF A PLAN FOR HOW THEY PLAN
TO ROLL OUT THE SERIES OF
PRODUCTS FOR THE MOBILE DRIVER
LICENSE PROGRAM. SO WHO DID TE
DMV OVERSEE IT OR WOULD THAT B
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WOULD OVERSEE OR
WOULD THAT BE. WHAT THEY'LL
BRING IT OUTSIDE- PARTNER IN
THIS. WE HAVE THE SPECIFICS.
YES I- MANY STATE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAMS I DMD I
WOULD WORK WITH A CONTRACTOR IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CITY TO HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT OVER
THE PROJECT OKAY BUT HAS THAT
HAS THAT BEEN GOING OUT AS AT
THAT DATE GOING OUT TO SEEK
THOSE ALREADY OR. DMV HAS
DEVELOPED A ROBUST IDEA ABOUT
HOW THEY WOULD PURSUE THIS- THE
GIVEN THAT THE- FUNDING WAS
JUST APPROVED ON THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR IDEA V. AS IN.
PROCESS YET. OKAY IF YOU KEEP
ME POSTED ON THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND THAT WAS MY
QUESTIONS MR. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHAT. YES SIR THANK YOU THIS IS
MORE OUR COMMENTS AROUND THE
CANNABIS TRAILER BILL WHICH IS
AB S. B. ONE FORTY ONE- PROVIDE
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR- AND
THE STAFF BUDGET COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS A SPEAKER STAFF THE
HEART. THAT THE HOURS OF HARD
WORK THAT HAVE GONE INTO THIS
ISSUE. I'M SURE YOU ALL KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE IS VERY
IMPORTANT MY DISTRICT AND ONE
THAT I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING ON OVER THE PAST SIX
YEARS. I KNOW ALL TOO WELL HOW
COMPLICATED AND DYNAMIC THE
PROBLEMS ARE THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO SOLVE HERE. OF OUR LINE FOR
MY SENATE COLLEAGUES PROP SIXTY
FOUR REQUIRE THE STATE. AND
LOCAL PARTNERS TO BUILD THE
PLANE WHILE WE'RE FLYING IT.
LISTEN TO A LOT OF CONCERNS
FROM STAKEHOLDERS FROM EVERY
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER CLEAN UP MEASURE-
FOLLOWING THIS ONE IN IN VERY
SHORT ORDER. I BELIEVE WE HAVE
AN AGREEMENT BUT I'M ASKING THE
CHAIR TO CONFIRM THAT THIS
CLEANUP BILL WILL. NUMBER ONE
CLARIFY HOW APPLICANTS CAN
DEMONSTRATE SEQUEL COMPLIANCE
IN JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE MADE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE STATE. THAT
ARE NOT CURRENTLY LAID OUT IN
AB S. B. ONE FORTY ONE. THIS
WILL INCLUDE A PATHWAY FOR
GROWERS IN MENDOCINO COUNTY-
THAT THAT HAVE A- LIKE- A
MEDICINE- COUNTY. THAT HAVE A
CHECKLIST APPROACH. NUMBER TO
ADD LANGUAGE IT MAKES CLEAR
THAT IF THE LEAD AGENCY HAS
COMPLIED WITH SEEK WHERE THEY
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO COMPLY WITH
THE SEQUEL MET BENCHMARKS IN
THIS BILL. NUMBER THREE. DELAY
THE DEADLINE FOR CDFA TO
ESTABLISHING APPELLATIONS OF
ORIGIN PROCESS TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND FOUR
CLARIFY THAT IT IS THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT NO
FURTHER EXEMPTIONS FROM ANNUAL
LICENSURE UNDERSEA QUOTE WILL
BE ADOPTED. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WITH THESE COMMITMENTS IN
PLACE I BELIEVE WE'RE SETTING
UP A FRAMEWORK. THAT MOVES THE
BALL FORWARD AND CHARTS A PATH
FOR A HEALTHY. LEGAL AND
SUSTAINABLE CANISTER CANIBUS
INDUSTRY FOR- FOR DECADES TO
COME. I RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
FOR THE FALL AND FOR THE FOLLOW
UP MEASURE TO COME. YES I'M I'M
NOT HAPPY TO CONFIRM THAT YES
IT DOES DO ALL THOSE- THOSE
FOUR DIFFERENT POINTS I DON'T
KNOW FINANCE WANTS TO. CLARIFY
OR MAKE ANY COMMENT. YES MY
QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE
KIMBERLY HARRISON. GOOD MORNING
KIMBERLY HARVESTING DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
CONFIRM THAT YES WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ON A CLEAN UP TRAILER
BILL. AND I THINK WE ALL HAVE
THE- THE SAME GOAL TO GET. THIS
MOST FOLKS AS WE CAN INTO THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE SYSTEM IN
THE LEGAL MARKET IT MAY MEAN.
THEY'RE IN THERE FOR A LITTLE
BIT LONGER AS THEY WORK TOWARD
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE BUT
THAT IS OUR GOAL TO GET
EVERYONE. TO AN ANNUAL LICENSE
I JUST NOTE THAT WE'VE ALSO
PROVIDED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- GENERAL FUND OF THE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THAT'S BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF. A
PROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSES SO WE ARE
OFFERING MONEY TO HELP THESE
FOLKS MOVE THINGS FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE NOT
GONNA MISS GARCIA. BUT THANK
YOU COMMENT AND NOT ACTUALLY
QUESTIONS- FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE SB ONE
FORTY THREE WITH SOME
AGREEMENTS BUT WE STILL HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT WE NEED TO
DISCUSS INCLUDING HOW WE
ESTABLISH REMOTE FOR HEARINGS
IN A WAY THAT'S FAIR TO OUR
EMPLOYEES OUT THERE ARE WORKERS
AND THEN TAXES THEM ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE A GOOD LAST SIX
TWO QUARTS. OUT THERE WE ARE
ALSO STILL- TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO WE CAN MAKE SURE WE
GIVE RATE RATE INCREASES TO
COURT REPORTER TRANSCRIPT RATES
WHICH HAVE NOT BEEN INCREASED
IN OVER THREE DECADES- THAT TO
WORK FOR SEPARATE THAT IS
PREDOMINATELY FEMALE AS THE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IT
IS REALLY FRUSTRATING TO SEE
THAT WE HAVE IN REPORT ON THAT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO.
CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE
HOPEFULLY GET TO A CONCLUSION
I'M DURING THE SUMMER. RECESS
AND THEN THE SECOND ITEM THAT I
WANTED TO BRING UP IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND GIVEN
THAT ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATORY
AUTHORITY. IS A PRIORITY- AND
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT TO THAT. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON REFORMS IT'S
REALLY TROUBLING WHEN WE KEEP
READING ARTICLES IN THE LA
TIMES ABOUT THE TROUBLES IN OUR
PRISONS MOST RECENTLY HEARING
ABOUT. A STALEMATE DECAPITATED
HIS CELL MATE A PROCESS THAT
WAS FOR TRISTAN WENT ON FOR
HOURS YEAH YEARS AGO. WENT ON
FOR HOURS AND NO ONE WAS AWARE
OF IT- AND HOW THAT HAPPENS IS
NOT CLEAR TO ME OR TO ANYONE.
AYE AYES ARE REALLY TROUBLING
AND SO I HOPE THAT. AS THE
SUMMER GOES ON WE COME TO A
CONCLUSION AND WERE ABLE TO GET
A RESOLUTION THERE. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST BEING
REACTIONARY TO THE MANY
LAWSUITS THAT COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY. AND WE'RE ACTUALLY.
HONORING OUR PROMISES OUT THERE
TO TREAT ALL INDIVIDUALS FAIRLY
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE- AT AS WELL. AND SO
JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT FLAG
DOWN I AM HAPPY OF THE PROGRESS
WE HAVE MADE- TO THE STATE ON.
SOME OF THESE ITEMS BUT THESE
ITEMS. THAT ARE OUTSTANDING ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT I DO HOPE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO COME TO A
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- MISS FIRST THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
APPLAUD THE- BUDGET STAFF FOR
AB ONE THIRTY SIX- THIS WAS A
LONG TIME COMING AND A LOT OF
WORK WENT INTO THIS EFFORT AND
AFTER READING. THE TEXT OF THIS
BILL IT'S THE BEST I'VE SEEN IN
A LONG TIME FOR THIS POPULATION
IT'S COMPREHENSIVE IT'S ACTION
ORIENTED OUTCOME ORIENTED
THERE'S METRICS IN THERE FOR
PERFORMANCE IT'S YOU KNOW A
DREAM COME TRUE. AND I JUST
WANT TO REMIND YOU KNOW ALL OF
US THAT THIS WAS YOU KNOW BOUND
BY THE RATE STUDY THAT WAS
THREE YEARS AGO AND THE FULL
YEAR THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION
WILL BE. IN TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. OKAY SO THIS WAS AN
AUGMENTATION TO THE POPULATION
THIS WAS TO CATCH UP TO THE
DEFICIENCIES THAT WERE
ACTUALLY- DENOTED IN THE RATE
STUDY. SO YOU KNOW WE WANT A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
FURTHER THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
THIS POPULATION BUT I ALSO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT THIS WAS
JUST A ZERO SUM GAME THIS
CAUGHT US UP. AND WE SHOULD NOT
BE COMPLACENT WE SHOULD BE ALSO
WORKING FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INFLATIONARY MEASURES GOING
FORWARD AND THE INCREASING
POPULATION WHICH- INCREASES 25%
IN A DECADE IN TEN YEARS. IS
THAT DIMINISHES THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF WHAT WE PUT
INTO IT. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE PRISON POPULATION. I
THINK WE SPEND ABOUT EIGHTY
SOMETHING THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PRISONER. BUT AS OF NOW WITHOUT
THIS IMPLEMENTATION WE WERE
PAYING TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER CONSUMER. IT'S
GOING TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AND
THAT ALSO I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
BUDGET BUDGET COMMITTEE. FROM
THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHER. COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I'M NOT SEEING ANY WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THIRTY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
THE GALLERY AT TWO ONE PERSON
MOVING. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE SUPPORT THE S. B.
AB ONE FIFTY AND THE EXPANSION
OF THE HIRING CREDIT AS WELL AS
THE- HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL
CREDIT. AND WE ALSO SUPPORT A
B. S. B. ONE FIFTY ONE AND THE
ADDITIONAL GRANT PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY FOR A LIVE VENUES
AND PERFORMING ARTS CENTERS
WHICH HAVEN'T BENEFITED FROM
PRIOR GRANT EFFORTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENT HERE. OKAY NO SEE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AT&T OR OPERATOR
YOU THERE. YES MR CARE I'M HERE
VERY GOOD ANY COMMENT. YES WE
HAVE A NUMBER ALREADY QUEUED UP
AND TO GIVE THE INSTRUCTIONS
ALL GO AHEAD OUT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME IN EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE IS
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND PLACE
IT BACK IN THE QUEUE AGAIN DO.
A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I JUST A QUICK
QUESTION ARE YOU TAKING-
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION UP THE
SAME TIME MISTER CHAIR YES
WE'RE TAKING ALL PUBLIC COMMENT
THE STAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE ON MUTE YOU
ARE OPEN. MARGE SCHOTT TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE ON YOUR PHONE. I'M
MOVING ALONG WITH A LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS LORI KAMMER ON BEHALF
OF SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS
CALIFORNIA NAPA CALIFORNIA- I
WANTED TO- LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS- ON THE
OUTSIDE AB S. B. ONE FIVE ONE.
REGARDING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
FIND AND THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL- ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM- WE BELIEVE THAT THESE-
SHOULD BE SEPARATE- PROGRAMS-
YOU HAVE AN EXISTING SMALL
BUSINESS KATE PROGRAM AND THEN
THE- THIRTY FIVE MILLION THAT
HAS BEEN- A PROPOSED TO BE
ALLOCATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FUND- YET THERE IS. NO
FUNDING IDENTIFIED FOR THE
CONTINUANCE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS STATE PROGRAM SO WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE BUDGET STAFF IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE TAPE
PROGRAM. IS FUNDED THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA LINE. TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING CARE MEMBERS
CRYSTAL HEAT OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS- ADVOCATES
EXPRESSED MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE IN
PARTICULAR A CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT. PERFORMING ARTS
GRANT PROGRAM NONPROFIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTION CALIFORNIA
LIVE EVENTS PROGRAMS THE
RECOVERY ABOUT ART CULTURE AND
MIGHT EVENT INDUSTRY AND
WORKFORCE WE ALSO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE FORTY NINE
CLEAN CALIFORNIA LOCAL GRANT
PROGRAM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHAT IN THE FIFTEENTH INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR ARTISTS IN THE
GRANT PROGRAM TO BE TO FIND
CLEAN UP LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS AND OTHER PUBLIC SPACES.
AS OPPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE- WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR DEEP APPRECIATION FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THE BUDGET OVERALL
TO INCLUDE STARK INVESTMENT FOR
ARTS. CULTURE AND CREATIVITY
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING HMMWV COMMITTEE
AND THEY CONGRATULATE THANKS TO
ALL WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD-
OVERTAXED FEELING MY NAME IS
BIANCA I'M QUITE ON BEHALF OF
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY- WE DO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF THE
NEW HIGHER TAX CREDIT AND AN
ADDITION. UPON REVIEWING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AB SB ONE
FIFTY ONE BE AMENDED COULD
BUILD UPON THE SUCCESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEMONSTRATED BY THE-MARKETS NINE EIGHT PROGRAM. WE
HOPE THAT YOU IN THE BUDGET
BACK AND SURE THAT THE TAPE
PROGRAM IS EXTENDED BEYOND THAT
FIVE YEAR PILOT PERIOD AND
ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FIND FUNCTION AS A
SEPARATE PROGRAM SB TAPE. BY
ALLOTTING TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO
THE BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
TWO YEAR OLD. HELLO THIS IS
CLAUDIA V. AND I AM THE AB FOR
THE WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER
NETWORK CONSISTING OF SIXTEEN
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND I'M
CALLING TO- TALK ABOUT ASPECTS
OF THE EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY AT THE ONE FIFTY ONE- WE
URGE YOU STRONGLY TO SEPARATE
THE THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
NEW DREAM FIND DIRECT GRANT
PROGRAM TO START UP BUSINESSES.
JUST SEPARATED FROM THE
EXISTING SMALL BUSINESS TAKE
PROGRAM AND TO ADD SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER THE
COST OF THE INTENSIVE SCREENING
AND TRAINING AND COACHING AS
WELL AS THE MANAGEMENT AND DATA
COLLECTION THAT THE DREAM PLAN
WILL REQUIRE. THE DREAM FAT
GRANT FUNCTIONS ARE OVER AND
ABOVE THE CURRENT SERVICES
PROVIDED BY YOUR CAPE GRANT
SHEET THAT OPERATE IN YOUR
LOCAL DISTRICTS. I DON'T WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE LTS OF THE
CURES ACT TWENTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION TO- BOB THIS IS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GROUP
WHICH WILL HAPPEN AFTER
SEPTEMBER THIS YEAR AND THAT'S
GOING TO PUT MORE PRESSURE ON
THE PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW THAT
DEMAND REMAINS HIGH FROM YOUR
SMALL AND MICRO BUSINESSES AND
I THINK YOU ALSO SAW THE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED LETTERS THAT WERE
SENT IN FROM THESE BUSINESSES
AND SUPPORT OF FUNDING FOR THE
TAPE. OKAY SO PLEASE DO NOT
CANNIBALIZE YOUR EXISTING AND
ALREADY PRESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ADDING NEW
PROGRAMS WEARING THEM ON
WITHOUT NEW FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THEM. IF THE GREEN FUND GRANTS
ARE TO REACH TO FOLKS WHO NEED
THEM IT SHOULD BE SEPARATED
FROM EXISTING CAPE. SMALL
BUSINESS PROGRAMS AND HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OPERATIONS THANKS A
LOT. SIX OF THE LINE. THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JENNIFER GANG
EXPRESSING GRATITUDE AND
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE NOT
MINE FOUNDATION AND THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION
FOR THE LANGUAGE IN SECTION ONE
ASSEMBLY DOT ONE FORTY NINE
GRANTING AUTHORITY TO ABOUT THE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO CONSIDER
AND APPROVE MEANING OF NON
VEHICULAR WILDLIFE CROSSING
WILL HOPE TO SPUR PRIVATE
PUBLIC PARTNERSHIPS TO ENSURE
INVESTMENT IN CONSERVATION AND
BIODIVERSITY PROJECTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO PROTECT AND
RECOVER KEY. WILDLIFE EATING
BETTER UNDER EVER INCREASING
PRESSURE WANT TO SPECIFICALLY
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BLUMEN
FRIEDMAN AND FORMER STARTING IN.
BALLOTS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU. MY FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS HEIDI
PICKMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAMEO I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE EVERYBODY ON
THE GREAT WORK BEING DONE ON AB
ONE FIFTY ONE TO SUPPORT SMALL
AND MICRO BUSINESSES AND WANT
TO- ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE REGARDING
THE TAPE PROGRAMS- THERE'S BEEN
THE WOMEN'S BUSINESS AND
THERE'S A CALCULATED THAT A
DOLLAR INVESTED IN THE PAID
PROGRAM HAS RETURNED A HUNDRED
NINETY TWO DOLLARS. AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY ONE MAKE SURE
THAT STAYS INTACT THOSE ARE
REALLY- THAT'S A VERY GOOD
INVESTMENT- AND THAT THE DREAM
FUND IS- EXECUTED AS A SEPARATE
PROGRAM- THE TAPE PLANS ARE
FUNDS THAT ARE GOING FOR SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT IN THE
DREAM KIND OF FUNDS THAT ARE
GOING TO DIRECTLY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THERE. THEY HAVE
TO CONNECTION- SO I URGE YOU
TO- ADDS THAT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THOSE
CRIMES. THANK YOU. FIND NINE UP
TO GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DIANA
WHAT ACTIVE CALIFORNIA AB ONE
THIRTY THREE WE'RE THRILLED THE
BUDGET WILL INCLUDE MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR EACH FIFTY PLUS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE MOMENTUM THAT. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE BUDGET
INCLUSION OF ELIMINATING THE
BODY CAL APPETITE INCREASE
DAMAGE EQUALITY AND EQUITY
METRICS FOR HEALTH PLANS
SUPPORTING TRUE ZERO PREMIUM
COVERAGE IN COVERED CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO FOR A CHOIR IN THE
COVER CALIFORNIA REPORT ON
OPTIONS TO REDUCE COST SHARING
IN THE MARKETPLACE IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK ON THE
BUDGET. ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBER IS AN APPLICATION ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN REGARD
TO EVN SB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE THERE'S SO MUCH GOOD IN
THE BUDGET AND WE APPRECIATE
THE HARD WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT YOU DONT
REBUILD I TOWARDS EQUITY IN SO
MANY ASPECTS OF THIS BUDGET
REFLECT THAT. HOWEVER AS OUR
STATE REIMAGINE OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM C. F. P. REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT THE CHANGE THE
OFFICE. OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. ONE
OF HEALTH CARE ACT AND FROM.
DOESN'T PROVIDE ADEQUATE. IN
ELIMINATING THE STATE'S PRIMARY
CARE SHORTAGE WHICH IS THE KEY
STRATEGY IN PROVIDING MORE AND
BETTER PATIENT CARE. IN
PARTICULAR THE COMPOSITION OF
THE COUNCIL DOES NOT REINFORCE
PLANNING FOR PRIMARY CARE. WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE SOME OF
THE PIECES THAT WERE TAKEN INTO
THE MODIFIED TRAILER BILL. NOW
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU TO FURTHER THE GOAL
OF ENSURING ADEQUATE PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE. THAT REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA NEEDS. THANK YOU.
COOPER LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE ON
HEALTHCARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB ONE THIRTY SIX ON BEHALF OF
CMG KHALIFA WE REGRET TO-
OPPOSE AB ONE FORTY ONE THERE'S
A LOT IN THAT BILL THAT IS VERY
VERY GOOD- THERE IS ONE IS A
PIECE AND IT IS STILL NOT BEEN
FIXED AND- NOT WITHSTANDING DR
WHAT SUMMARY OF AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE COMING. AND
WE'RE STILL NOT DEALING WITH
THE ISSUE OF LARGER CULTIVATORS
WHO WILL BE JAMMED THROUGH- THE
SEQUEL PROCESS IN ONE YEAR-
INSTEAD OF THE FOUR YEARS
ALLOWED TO EVERYBODY ELSE IF WE
WANT TO PROTECT ALL LEGAL
ACTORS WE NEED TO PROTECT ALL
LEGAL ACTORS AND NOT PUT SOME
AND HAD OF OTHERS- THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF LICENSES THOUSANDS
OF JOBS AND MILLIONS IN TAX
REVENUE THAT WILL BE AT RISK AT
THE ED OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
EARLY TWENTY THREE. IF WE DO
NOT ALLOW THE LARGER
CULTIVATORS TO HAVE THE SAME
ABILITY TO GET SEQUEL
COMPLIANCE- BY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD KING
AND MEMBERS I'M LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
COMMENTING ON AB ONE FIFTY ONE.
WE APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
NONPROFITS AND SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM THE
ADDITIONAL CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS GRANT ROUNDS AND
ALL OF THE FUNDING FOR
PERFORMING ARTS NONPROFITS AND
VENUES. BUT IN OUR ROLE AS THE
VOICE FOR NONPROFITS IN
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER CONTRACTED
PARTNER FOR THE RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM WE CONTINUE TO HEAR
FROM APPLICANTS. ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS. INCLUDING
THOUSANDS OF NONPROFITS
COMPLETED THE WRONG APPLICATION
BECAUSE THE NONPROFIT
APPLICATION WITH NOT
IMMEDIATELY VISIBLE ON THE
GRANT PROGRAM FIGHT. AT WHO
COMPLETED THE WRONG APPLICATION
NOT RECEIVED ADEQUATE NOTICE
ABOUT THEIR ERROR AND DESPITE
COMPLETING ALL OF THE REQUIRED
PAPERWORK WERE DENIED A GRANT.
NONPROFIT APPLICANTS RECEIVED
POOR CUSTOMER SERVICE AND MIXED
MESSAGES FROM THE
INTERMEDIARIES CALL CENTER.
THESE ISSUES ARE LIKELY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE LOW
PERCENTAGES OF GRANT'S GOING TO
NONPROFIT THREE POINT 2% ACROSS
THE FIVE GENERAL ROUNDS AND
ONLY ONE POINT 8% FROM AROUND
FIVE. THE LAST ROUND WAS
FINALIZED DATA WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION ON WAYS TO
MAKE THIS PROGRAM MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO NON PROFITS TO
BETTER SUPPORT THEM AS THEY
RESPOND TO COMMUNITY NEEDS.
THANK YOU. WE WERE LINE. TEN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THE
INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COASTAL
GROWERS ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
MR MARTIN WITH RESPECT AB ONE
FORTY ONE- AND ALTHOUGH THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAITED FOR HIS
EFFORTS TO PURSUE ADDITIONAL
CLEANUP AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS
MISTER MARTIN- MENTIONED THERE
ARE STILL SOME OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS RELATIVE TO
CULTIVATION OPERATIONS AND
ACCESS TO THE MEDIUM LICENSE
TYPE. IF IT IS THE POLICY OF
THE STATE TO CONTACT EXISTING
PROVISIONAL LICENSE HOLDERS IN
THE PROCESS SHOULD BE EQUITABLE
FOR ALL LICENSE HOLDERS AND
THAT- THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE WORK AS MENTIONED
THERE ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS THAT MAY RESULT- BASED
ON THE EXISTING LANGUAGE- I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT RELATIVE
TO THE LOCAL GRANT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WE ARE VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE- THE INCLUSION
OF A HUNDRED MILLION Q. TRIED
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESSING OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSE HOLDERS.
AND WE WOULD JUST ASK THAT BE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED- IN THE CLEAN
UP BILL CONSIDER THE PINING
WITH WHICH BACK FUNDING WILL BE
ALLOCATED WE NEED TO ENSURE IT
DOESN'T SYNC WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
WILL BE IMPOSED ON LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THEY GET THAT
MONEY FOR THEY CAN PROCESS
THOSE APPLICATIONS. TIMELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT TO GO
TO MY FORTY FOUR YEAR ARE OPEN.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS- MARVIN
PANETTA WE HAVE THE AT CAVS IN
THE NATION IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FORTY ONE. WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT ALL
AGENCIES CONSOLIDATE INTO ONE.
THERE ARE SOME OUTSTANDING
ISSUES- WHAT THAT BILL BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. TO ENSURE
THAT- EVERYONE IS TREATED
EQUALLY AT THE SAME TIME THE
DECISION ARE DONE IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR EFFORTS AND ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE. AND OUR NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE FROM
NINE THIRTY TO. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS NINA PARKS AND I AM
REPRESENTING THAT- THAT COULD
BE TREATED OF CATION AS WELL AS
A BOARD MEMBER SUPERNOVA WOMEN-
WOMEN OF COLOR ORGANIZATION
CANNABIS- AND CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS- EQUITY. ALLIANZ SO-
MY COMMENT IS IN REGARDS TO AB
ONE FORTY ONE- OUR OUR POLICY
STILL LACK DEFINITION FOR
SOCIAL EQUITY WHICH IS REALLY
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE- AS LEADERS.
INVESTED IN THE SPACE THAT A
POLICY WHERE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THEY'RE ADOPTING SOCIAL
EQUITY PROVISIONS IN THEIR
POLICIES TO BE LEGALIZED
CALIFORNIA LACKS STATE IN THEIR
STATE POLICY BUT HAS VERY
STRONG LOCAL POLICIES SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SOME ALIGNMENT IN
REGARDS TO THE DEFINITION- AND
THEN ALSO- JUST TO ECHO THE
INDUSTRIES THAT CAN TURN AROUND
TIME LINE. A TIMELINE THAT WE
HAVE CURRENTLY ARE VERY
UNREALISTIC IN IN REGARDS TO
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
DEPARTMENT- AS WELL AS TO HOW
LONG IT HAS TAKEN THE BAR
EVERYONE IS STILL ON EITHER
TEMPORARY OR- PROVISIONAL
LICENSES AND HAVING GOTTEN
THEIR ANNUAL LICENSES- JUST
UNDER REALISTIC TIMELINES IF WE
CAN MOVE THEM OUT SO THAT
IMPLEMENT. THE IMPLEMENTATION
DOESN'T CREATE UNNECESSARY-
EXTINCTION EVENT. IT WOULD BE
VERY. I DO PAGE. SO YEAH THAT
IS THE BASE OF THE COMMON THANK
YOU. AND WE WERE LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
THIRTY FOUR CAN NOW REST.
THIRTY FOR YOUR OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY THIS IS
MISTER CARE MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF BESSIE ARGUE
CALIFORNIA COMMENTS ON TO THE
TRAILER IS UP FIRST AB S. B.
ONE THIRTY SIX DOT NET STRIKE
HUGE THANKS IT'S A BIG THING
ABOUT THE RATES BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY. JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY IT'S ABOUT. HOW HOW
WE TREAT PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE THANKFUL
FOR THE LANGUAGE ACCESS CALLED
SCHOOL COMPETENCY IN PLOT TO
BIAS TRAINING. THAT INCLUDED IN
THE BILL WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT THE-
MOVEMENT FOR A BETTER RATE
SHOWS PER SERVICE COORDINATORS
AND TO CLIENTS. AND WE'RE
REALLY HAPPY FROM THE TRAINING
FOR DSPS AND ADDS BACKED WITH
THE TRAININGS TIED YEAH
ACTUALLY IN COMMON SOME PEOPLE
MAKE THIS THEIR CAREER INSTEAD
OF. CONTESTS OF LOVED. AND THEN
AND THEN THERE WAS THE OUTCOME
MEASURES IT ADDED A GUIDE- THE
PUSH TOWARD SELF DETERMINATION
AND DOING MORE THAT THE MORE
THANKFUL CARLOS THANK- WE THINK
THIS BILL IS FINALLY AND LONG
OVERDUE- IN REGARD TO S. B. AB
ONE FORTY ONE WERE IN SUPPORT
REFLECTS. CRITICAL THAT THE-
GET. IT LOCAL GET THE MONEY TO
ACTUALLY BE ABLE. TO CREATE A
STEP DIRECT THEM TO SAY AND DO
A BALL PATHWAY TOWARDS
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE DO YOU
THINK THAT SPENT MESSING THE
WHOLE TIME IN THE BILL. AND IN
SUCH PROP SIXTY FOUR PASSED.
AND WE ALSO- THANK THAT IS
COMBINING THE AGENCIES WHO. IS
CRITICAL TO MAKING THE
REGULATIONS MORE STREAM LINED.
UP SO WE TAKE THE BILL'S GOOD
WE THINK THERE THAT THERE'S- AS
LONG AS THERE'S A CLEAR PATHWAY
AND PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO AND
WILLING TO COMPLY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
THAT'S A GOOD THING AND WE-
ALSO WANT TO. ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM THE CORE ALLIANCE IT YES.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR ADDING A-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. FOR UP EQUITY
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THERE'S
FINALLY A PATHWAY TO CREATE I'M
GOING FUNDING FOR THAT BUT YES
HAVING DEFINITION. THAT
COMBINED WHAT ACTUALLY IS
PROBABLY CRITICAL THAT. AND THE
STATE NEEDS. TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION THANK YOU MUCH. HELLO
GO TO LINE YOUR OPEN. HELLO
GOOD MORNING SECURE MEMBERS JIM
QUALITY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GOOD PARTNERSHIP- WE
HAVE A POSITION OF SUPPORT OF
AMENDED ON AB ONE THREE ONE.
FROM THE VIEWPOINT OF THE
PARTNERSHIP- THERE ARE THREE
KEY DEFICIENCIES FIRST IT FAILS
TO ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE
SOCIAL EQUITY DEFINITION WE'VE
SUBMITTED LANGUAGE FOR THIS TO
LEADERSHIP AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES- SUCH A DEFINITION
WILL HELP THE STATE A PROVIDING
EVALUATION CRITERIA FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION OF EQUITY GRANTS
GOING FORWARD. AND TO ABIDE WE
WOULD CONSTITUTE A BONA FIDE
SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESS IN THE
STATE LICENSING PROCESS CHECK
IT IT DOES NOT CLEARLY DEFINE
THE AUTHORITY OF THE NEWLY
CREATED POSITION OF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CORRECTLY AND
INCLUSION WITHIN THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
THIS POSITION SHOULD HAVE ITS
OWN BUDGET AND STATUTORY
AUTHORITY OVER THE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES INVOLVED IN
CANNABIS LICENSING WITH A VIEW
TOWARD INCREASING LICENSES. OF
SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESS. THIRD
AND FINALLY IT DOES NOT.
CURRENT OLD. FOR LOCAL GRAN.
WHICH IS NOW LIMITED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ONLY LOCAL
NONPROFITS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO APPLY DIRECTLY TO KOBE IS
FOR THOSE MONEY AS WELL. AS A
MEANS OF HELPING TO ENSURE THAT
THE FUNDS ARE GOING TO THE
INTENDED RECIPIENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE LINE EIGHT YOUR
OPEN. HELLO HI THIS IS SHERRY
FRANKLIN WITH THINKING GROW LAB
ENERGY MUCH HYPE- WE APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS OF OUR ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE AND THANK YOU TO SENATOR
STEVEN BRADFORD FOR MAKING SURE
THAT SOCIAL EQUITY IS INCLUDED
NUMBER ONE- THE BILL SHOULD
DEFINITELY NOT. I OUR TIES GUN
FOR AGENCIES WE DON'T NEED MORE
GUNS WE'RE NOT MEET DR WORK TO
CAMINO. THE ISSUE IS WE NEED TO
BE SOCIAL MEDIA SHE- IF
PROVISIONAL PLATE- NOW SHOULD
BE ABLE PROVIDED FOR ALL. NEW
APPLICANTS AT LEAST THREE YEARS
GIVEN THE CHANCE GET TO THE
ARGUES PROCESS HELLO LEVEL AND-
THE OTHER THING THE C. WE CAN
INNOVATE. WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH THE- AND DO CHECKLIST OF
WHAT THE APPLICANT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. ALSO WE MAKE SURE WE
GET THEM. I HAD THE LICENSES
THAT ARE NOT. COMPATIBLE AND
ENVIRONMENT SUCH AS RETAIL
DELIVERY SO FORTH WE NEED TO BE
INNOVATIVE SO WE CAN GIVE
BUSINESSES THE CHANCE. AND THE
OTHER ISSUE. IS WE NEED TO FIND.
STATE THE BANK DOES HAVE ENOUGH
READ. TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
PROVIDE THE KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. WITH THE LOCAL
PROCESS ALSO COORDINATING WITH
OTHER DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS- FISH
AND GAME AND THE WATER BOY IT'S
A DISCURSIVE NIGHTMARE FOR
APPLICANTS. AND THAT'S WHAT
ALONG EIGHT THE PROCESS. WE
NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTAND LIKE USING AT THE
STATE LEVEL ACTIVITY LEVELS
THAT. HAVE THAT KIND OF DARK OR
PERSON IN BETWEEN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE- NOTHING HAPPENED.
IN A WAY THAT IS TIMELY HEY
BRETT FOREVER THOSE ARE THE
MAIN THINGS WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK- WITH THE STATE
ANALYSTS. ALL OF OUR- FRIENDS
AT THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENT
DON'T- AND NOT DEPARTMENT
AGENCIES DON'T TRY YOUR HAND WE
WANT TO DO THIS RIGHT WE'VE
BEEN RESPONSIBLE AND WE THINK
WE CAN GET THIS RIGHT WE NEED
TIME TO DO IT. WITH RUSSIA'S
PROSPECTS NEED TO TAKE A STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT THE ITEM. THAT
WE GET IT RIGHT THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IGNACIO
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS- WE HAVE BEEN
SERIOUS CONCERNS REGARDING
EIGHTY ONE FORTY THREE
SPECIFICALLY THE COMPETITION
WHICH WILL ALL GET A BLANKET
AUTHORIZATION FOR REMOTE.
HEARINGS BOTH- TRIAL IN NON
TRIAL INFRACTION CASES WHILE
INFRACTIONS MAY BE ON THE LOWER
END OF THE- SPECTRUM OF LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS I LANGUAGE ACCESS
NEEDS MEANING CRITICAL- DONE
SPECIFIED HOW INTERPRETERS WILL
BE PROVIDED TO THE INDIVIDUALS
HOW CONSENT WILL BE OBTAINED-
WITHOUT AN INTERPRETER YEAH
BEEN. PILOT PROJECTS IN FRESNO
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE WAS REMOTE
HEARINGS HOWEVER THAT REQUIRED
THE INTERPRETER TO BE IN PERSON
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL AT THE
SATELLITE. LOCATION WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT. IS THE INTENT
WITH THIS. RESIDENTS OF
ARKANSAS. LOS ANGELES COUNTY-
TOOK A TO THE CAN DOWN I WHERE
WE HOW DID NOT PERMIT ANY
TRIALS INFRACTIONS- WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL SHOULD BE RESTRICTED
I'M ALSO TO EXCLUDE TRIALS AND
YOU JUST NEED TO BE MORE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT THESE
PROCEEDINGS WILL LOOK LIKE HOW
THEY WILL BE HELD OTHERWISE WE
RISK A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS SUCH
AS THE ONE THAT WE HEARD IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY EARLIER THIS
YEAR WHERE A CONDITION ONCE
AGAIN SURGERY PERFORMED
SURGERY. ON DURING A TRAFFIC.
INFRACTION- TRIAL. REMOTELY- OF
COURSE BUT- SHUT DOWN THAT YOU
NEED- BUT THAT JUST UNDERSCORES
THE NEED TO HAVE MUCH MORE
SPECIFIC SYMBOLS. BEFORE THIS
PROVISION. IS ENACTED- THOSE
CONCERNS WE HAVE. WHAT WE WANT
WE WILL ALIGN FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ALBERTO TO
RECALL WE HAVE A OF THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SB ONE FORTY ONE
ECONOMIST FORMER TRAILER BILL.
WE BELIEVE THAT- GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THE ILLICIT ILLEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET OPERATIONAL
LEGAL MARKET BY AT LEAST A
FACTOR OF THREE TO ONE. IT IS
EVIDENT ASCENTIAL THE
DEPARTMENT GET UP AND RUNNING
THE CONSOLIDATION WILL WILL
BRING ABOUT GREATER ENFORCEMENT
WE ALSO WANTED LEARNERS
OVERCOME WHICH DOCTOR WOULD IN
TERMS OF. LOOKING FORWARD TO A
LONG LONG DISCUSSIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL CLEANUP LANGUAGE.
WELL AT THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FINE FOR ONE YOUR-
JERRY CAN ONLY HAPPEN THE REAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON AB
FORTY ONE FIRST YOU WANT TO SAY
THAT WE SUPPORT THE PROVISIONS
TO CONSOLIDATE THE THREE
LICENSING AGENCIES INTO A NEW
DEPARTMENT INSIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS OF THE LANGUAGE
EXTENDING THE CANNABIS
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
PROPOSED TIMELINE AND THE NEED
TO ENSURE FULL RANGE OF
COMPLIANCE MECHANISMS UTILIZED
BY LEAD AGENCIES. TO MEET THE
STATE HE COULD HAVE SEEK
OBLIGATIONS FOR CANNABIS LIKE
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS EARLIER ON
GRATITUDE FOR THE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND- ANY
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING THAT
MONEY OUT TO THE JURISDICTION
OF QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND MY
ON THE CURRENT TIMELINES WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK HAS BEEN
DONE SO FAR THE COMMENTS MADE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT ANY
MINISTRATION LEGISLATURE'S
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
IN CLEAN UP LANGUAGE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE. DISCUSSIONS
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU. ANNEX THE LINE. FOR SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CARE MEMBERS
MICHAEL BACK WITH THE PREY IN
THE KEIGHLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION AND THEIR FORTY
FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS
ACROSS THE STATE VOICING
SUPPORT FOR A BI SB ONE FIFTY
PARTICULARLY THE HOMELESS
HIRING TAX CREDIT THIS CREDIT
WILL HELP TO CONNECT ON HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH BUSINESSES
LOOKING TO BOUNCE BACK TO THE
NUMEROUS ISSUES THEY FACED AN
ULTIMATELY LED TO BOTH OF THEM
NOT. AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
BUILD BACK WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE BUDGET STAFF
AS A MEMBER BERMAN HAS STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
SHARON MEMBERS MIGHT OUR
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSWELL AGENCIES ACROSS OUR
STATE IT'S WANTED TO JOIN YOU
TODAY TO EXPRESS THE TRANSIT
INDUSTRY THANK AND PROFOUND
APPRECIATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND YOUR
RESPECTIVE STAFF FOR DANCING
THE VERY STATUTORY RELIEF AND
FLEXIBILITY- MEASURES FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES
INCLUDED SB ONE FORTY NINE AND
AB ONE FORTY NINE THAT
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL- AS
YOU KNOW DESPITE SEVERAL ROUNDS
OF FEDERAL EMERGENCY REALLY
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE TO REGAIN THEIR
FOOTING THESE MEASURES WILL
HELP US GET THROUGH OUR NEAR
TERM PANDEMIC RELATED
CHALLENGES AS WE REBUILD AND
WORK TO IMPROVE OUR SERVICES
WITH ACT THAT DEFICIENT THE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND FOCUS.
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY YOUR OPEN.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF THE ORIGINS
COUNSEL REPRESENTING LICENSEES
IN ALL SECTORS IN LEGACY
PRODUCING REGIONS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WANT TO SPEAK TO-
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY ONE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATIVE
ENGAGEMENT AND THE WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION THERE ARE
STILL CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
WE WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
BE. ABOUT THE NEED FOR CLEAN UP
BILL WE ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS WITH IN THE STATE
LICENSING SYSTEM THAT ARE
BECAUSE OF THE LACK. A MOVING
PERMIT DUTY. I WE'VE BEEN
ASKING TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ALL YEAR LONG
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION SB FIFTY
NINE IN THE SENATE. WE BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATURE MUST ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
SERIOUSLY WANT TO ACCELERATE
PEOPLE MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS FROM PROVISIONAL TAKING
YOUR LICENSURE- LINE WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
FOR THE DELAY IN THE
APPALACHIANS PROGRAM. THAT
PROGRAM CREATED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN PREVIOUS YEARS
IS ALREADY RECOGNIZED AS A
WORLD CLASS MODEL AND STANDARD.
HOWEVER THE REGULATORY ROLLOUT
HAS FAILED MISERABLY HOPEFULLY
THE ADDITIONAL TIME WILL ALLOW
THE PROGRAM TO BE STIRRED UP
CORRECTLY AND ACTUALLY CAN.
MAKE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO ON
FOURTEEN YOUR OPEN. GOOD
MORNING- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS DAVID
NELSON I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- CALLING IN
REGARDS TO- CALLING IN EGARDS
TO AB S. B. ONE FIFTY ONE. IN
STRONG SUPPORT- SB TAKE PROGRAM
HAS AS YOU ALL HEARD FROM OUR-
FELLOW NETWORK PROVIDERS
EARLIER IN THE TESTIMONY IT'S A
STRONG PROGRAM IT CONTINUES TO
DELIVER RESULTS FOR BUSINESS
OWNERS IN ALL OF YOUR DISTRICT.
AND WE JUST WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. WE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM PROGRAM IS IN
THE GRANT PROGRAM IT'S NOT A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THE TWO COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS OF DELIVERABLES AND
SO WE DO THINK THAT DOES NEED
TO BE SEPARATED ACCORDINGLY.
AND AS A AS OF MY COLLEAGUE
ALSO REP- REFERENCE THERE IS A
DROP THERE IS A COMING DROP IN
FEDERAL FUNDING- FROM THE TEARS
ACT AND SO WE ARE ASKING FOR
THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION TO
AUGMENT THAT AND TO PROVIDE THE
CONTINUAL NEED A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE BUSINESS
OWNERS IN YOUR DISTRICT. CHIU
NOT ONLY RECOVER BUT THEN TO BE
RESILIENT GOING FORWARD INTO
THIS NEW ECONOMY THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
THIS IS CARL WANTED. WE HAVE TO
FIND SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH I.
D. D. MY COMMENTS TODAY- WILL
PROCEED TO THE MAIN BUDGET BILL
ANY BSP ONE THIRTY SIX. WANT TO
START BY THINKING LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- SPECIFICALLY MEMBERS
FRAZIER ARAMBULA RUBIO HOLDING
MATHIS AND OTHERS FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF PUSHING FOR THE
SUPPORT OF OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS WITH. INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES. I DO
WANNA EXPRESS ONE WARNING THAT
IS- THE DELAY OF FUNDING UNTIL
APRIL THIS WILL PUT A LOT OF
PROGRAMS AT RISK ESPECIALLY AS
THEY ARE NOW COMING BACK TO
LIFE. THE PROBLEMS CREATED BY
THE YEARS OF CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING ESPECIALLY THE
DIFFICULTY HIRING AND RETAINING
OUR DIRECT CARE STAFF. WELL THE
ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO BETWEEN NOW AND
THE END OF THE YEAR WE'RE GOING
TO NEED FOR THEIR HELP IN
FUNDING THAT GAP- IF THE DESIRE
IS TO GET PROGRAMS TO REOPEN
SUCCESSFULLY. WE'RE ALSO
APPROACHING THE OUTCOME
MEASURES THAT MR FRAZIER
MENTIONED. WITH GREAT CAUTION
WE ARE STRONG OVERSIGHT BUT THE
LEGISLATURE SO THOSE TO NOT.
ALTER THE MOST IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLE THE LETTERMAN ACT OUT
OF A PERSON WITH I. D. D. BEING
ABLE TO MAKE CHOICES ABOUT
SUPPORTS. THAT MAKE HIS OR HER
LIFE FULFILLING AND NOT.
BECOMING LIMITED MENU THAT
LOOKS MORE LIKE A MANAGED CARE
SYSTEM. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
AND NEXT WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THIS
MATTHEW WITH ME REPEATING
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE OUR HE SAYS
HE'S AND APPRECIATION. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT WITH SB ONE
FIFTY NINE RESTORING LAST
YEAR'S PAY CUTS AND BENEFIT
REDUCTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND LINE FIFTY FIVE EUROPE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY FIVE
FOR UNITED. I AM. GLAD I'M SO
SORRY I WOULD NOT CARE FOR
THAT- GOOD AFTERNOON. THING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE GRATIEN AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER AT
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
REGULATION. LIKE SOME MEMBERS
OF TIS COMMITTEE DCR HAS MANY
CONCERNS THAT AB ONE POINT ONE
PROVISIONAL LICENSURE HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE UNNECESSARY
BRIDGE BETWEEN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF OUR RESPECTIVE
LICENSING AND REGULATORY
PROGRAM AND WE'RE RESPONSIBLE
NEGATIVE EQUITABLE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. THE CITY OF LA HAS
ISSUED OVER A THOUSAND
TEMPORARY APPROVALS FOR LOCAL
TEMPORARY LICENSES TO CANNABIS
BUSINESSES NONE OF THESE
BUSINESS HAVE AN ANNUAL STATE
LICENSE. UNDER THE CITIES LIES
ONLY SOCIAL EQUITY APPLICANTS
CAN APPLY FOR RETAIL DELIVERY
OR CULTIVATION LICENSES UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. HUNDREDS OF EXISTING
APPLICANTS MANY OF WHOM ARE
PURCHASED AND INNER CITY SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAM MAY NOT MEET
REQUIREMENTS. TO RECEIVE A
STATE PROVISIONAL LICENSE BY
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FURTHERMORE WITHOUT AN
EXTENSION OF THE ISSUANCE OF
THE STAY PROVISIONAL LICENSES
BEYOND JUNE THIRTIETH TRAIN
TRAIN TO HUNDREDS OF NEWS LOCAL
EQUITY APPLICANTS WON'T GET THE
BENEFIT OF PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE AND WON'T BE ABLE TO
OPERATE INTO THE EMPTINESS IT
LIKE LEGALLY IS CONNECTICUT.
NICOTINE **** STRATEGIC
PARTICULARLY SOCIAL APPLE. I
WANT TO MENTION THAT IS DEEPLY
GREAT INCREASE OF NEARLY JUST
LOCAL CURCHES CRAP SHOULD MANY
CHANGE CHANGE PROVISIONAL
CONTENT INTO THE YOU KNOW
LICENSING PROGRAM BUT WITH THAT
IN MIND AB CUBES IN EACH YEAR
MORE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE WERE LINE FORTY YOUR
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS CALLS FOR US WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION- WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND
PRICKLY THE STAFF'S HARD WORK
IN PUTTING TOGETHER ALL OF
THESE- THE LANGUAGES WELL AS
THE ANALYSIS IT'S ALWAYS
APPRECIATED BY THOSE OF US IN
THE THIRD HOUSE. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS
TO. AB S. B. ONE THREE THREE-
WE APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE
THOSE AMENDMENTS WE THANK THEM
FOR THAT FOR PROTECTING OUR
LICENSES. WE ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR DEEP APPRECIATION
AND GRATITUDE TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING
MEDICARE ACCESS- WE KNOW THAT
THIS WAS PUT INTO THE TRAILER
BILLS IN NO SMALL PART THANKS
TO THE EFFORTS OF MANY OF TH
FOLKS IN THIS ROOM SO WE WANT
TO THANK YOU DEEPLY. AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT- EXPANSION RELATED
TO THAT AS WELL WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DEAL THAT
WAS CRAFTED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE ON AB
THIRTY TWO FOUR EXPANDING
TELEHEALTH ACCESS TO MEDICARE
POPULATIONS- IS A TEMPORARY
ONE- WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THE
BUDGETING REASONING BEHIND
THIS. WE DO BELIEVE THAT FULLY
EXPANDING TELEHEALTH- PARITY
PAYMENTS THROUGH MEDICARE AL-
IS ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE IT'S
CONSISTENT WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
DOING WITH PRIVATE PAYERS-
PRIVATE INSURERS AND MANAGED
CARE PLANS SO WE WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT WE WOULD ALSO
HOWEVER NOTE THAT AS PART OF
THIS. TWO YEAR PROCESS- THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS TASKED WITH
STANDING UP A ADVISORY GROUP OF
FOLKS TO TALK ABOUT THE NEEDS I
WOULD ASK. YES THANK YOU. YEAH
MOVING ON WE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY FIVE YOUR OPEN PLEASE
UNMUTE. ONE MORE CHANCE THIRTY
FIVE IF YOU'D LIKE TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT. GOOD MORNING HERE YES
WE CAN. APOLOGIES GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER BURST PROSPER NOW
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY
GROWERS ALLIANCE I WANTED TO
MAKE A FEW COMMENTS ON EIGHTY
ONE FORTY ONE THE CAMPUS
TRAILER BILL- FIRST WANTED TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WORD FOR
HIS COMMENTS- WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF EXTENDING THE
DATE FOR APPALACHIANS
IMPLEMENTATION TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- TO ENSURE
THAT THAT PROGRAM IS SET UP
EFFECTIVELY AND HAS INTEGRITY-
WE ALSO SUPPORT. THE CONTINUED
ATTENTION TO CLEAN UP LANGUAGE
AROUND PROVISIONAL LICENSES
INCLUDING LOOKING AT THE
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS IN THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE IN THIS
CURRENT SITUATION AND ENSURING
THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE TIME
LINES AND THAT. LICENSE EACH
WERE MOVING FORWARD IN GOOD
FAITH- ACTIVELY AND DILIGENTLY
TO PURSUE AN ANNUAL LICENSE ARE
NOT ARTIFICIALLY KICKED OUT OF
LICENSING PROCESS FINALLY JUST
WANTED TO SHOW SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATION- WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO MINISTRATION ON
THE TRADE TEMPLES PROVISIONS
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE A PATHWAY TO ACCESS FOR
SMALL INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES.
THE FOURTEENTH WORKING WITH
REGULATORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
FRAMEWORK IS. HONORED IN THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THANK YOU.
OPERATORS OTHER. SLYNT SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MARTY AMADO FAMILY MEMBER OF A
PERSON- OLDER SISTER WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ALSO
UNPAID CARE GIVER TO AN
EXTENDED. FAMILY MEMBER WAS
TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD WITH DOWN
SYNDROME ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE IN THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING SUBCOMMITTEE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE HEALTH BUDGET
TRAILER BILL ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREA OF A MEDIC CAL TO PENSION-
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICES- BUDGET
TRAILER BILL STATIONARY OF
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY FOR
CHILDREN AGES THREE TO FOUR AND
ALSO THE FUNDING FOR THE RATES
STEADY THAT IS LINKED TO PERSON
CENTRED OUTCOMES. THOUGH AGREED
THAT IMPLEMENTATION IS
EVERYTHING ALSO URGE INCLUSION
OF SERVICES NOT IN THE RATE
STUDY INCLUDING HOUSING
SERVICES AND JUST A SHOUT OUT
TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
WHO HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
TREMENDOUS IN BEING RESPONSIVE
AND THE L. A. AND ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF COURSE ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER TERRY MEMBERS SMALL
PLANE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES CALLING J. TO
SUPPORT SB AB ONE THREE THREE
PROVIDERS YOU GRATEFUL FOR THAT
TO THE CHAIR MEMBERS AND STAFF
FOR THE BUDGET AND- AND BE NEW
INVESTMENTS ALLOW AT- TACKLE
THINGS SUCH AS PAPERWORK
REDUCTION. IMPLEMENTATION. IN
FORM THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS KIKI I AM IS BECAUSE
THE EQUITY OPERATOR IN THE CITY
OF LA REPRESENTING THE SOUTH
EQUITY OWNERS AMERICANS
ASSOCIATION I LIKE THE CONTACT
PHONE EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE
EFFORT HE LIKED IT BANK OF
CANADA BLACKLICK THE CAMPION
ACCORDION DIRECTLY IN THIS
INDUSTRY. AND WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE LOS ANGELES EPR
IT SURE WOULD BE ALMOST
CONSIDERED THE HARDSHIPS AND
BERRIER THE FROM THE EQUITY
APPLICATION THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE COULD ADDED DEFICIT AT
A STRONG DISADVANTAGED BUT THE
TIMELINE I'VE BEEN WAITING TWO
YEARS AND THE PROCESS WERE NOT
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION WHAT
GOES ON AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ESPECIALLY IN
REGARDS TO BOTH THE EQUITY AND
THE CRIME. THAT WE THINK THE
PLEASE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
THAT IN THE COMING WEEKS IN
ADDITION AND WE MUST HAVE A
STATE WIDE DEFINITION PROPOSAL
EQUITY AND ENGAGEMENT AT THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR POSITION WITH
INCLUSION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
CANNABIS CONTROL. PUT THAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE GONE BACK AND BACK
IN KOREA STORY PARKING AGENCIES
INVOLVED IN THE CANNABIS
LICENSING WHAT CAN YOU TOWARDS
INCREASING LICENSES FOR HEALTH
EQUITY I STRONGLY URGE WE
STRONGLY URGE THAT YOU
PRIORITIZE EQUITY IN THE.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE SIX YOUR- ONLY
IF THE- THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE BOARD MONEY
IS OUT FOR TOWARD NOT AND I'M-
MEMBER OF THE SO EQUITY BONUS A
WORKERS NOT WANT TO ASK THE
CALM THAT YOU CAN KEEP MAY AND
ALSO THE COMMON OF THE LOS
ANGELES ARE USED EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE HAVE A COMMON
USED AT OF WHAT SOCIAL EQUITY
IS SO AT THIS MONEY PISSED OUT
IT GOES TO THE RIGHT PARTY'S
THAT HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW A
DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED BY THE FAILED WAR
ON CANNABIS- AND- EQUITABLE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ONE THAT
REALLY PRIORITIZE SOCIAL EQUITY
OPERATORS IN THE SURVIVORS OF
THIS BILL. RACIALIZED LONG
CANNABIS I REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR BRADFORD WHICH
CAN'T BE- SOCIAL EQUITY IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
PRIORITIZED- THESE PROVISIONAL
LICENSE EXTENSION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE EQUITY
OPERATORS YOU KNOW SO- LOOKS
LIKE THIS IS LIKE LIKE RETAIL
IN IN DELIVERY. AND EVEN
DISTRIBUTION NECESSARILY DON'T
IMPOSE THE SAME YOU CANNOT-
ENVIRONMENTS- AFFECT AS-
CULTIVATION OR MANUFACTURING
NECESSARILY WITH SO WE NEED TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE. REALLY REALLY.
PRIORITIZE POSTS EQUITY IN
THAT'S HOW WE DEFINITELY LOVE
TO SOME A. B. ONE FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU YOUR TIME I. ANNEX
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOLLARS
TOWARDS THE STRATEGY THREE
SIXTY M. BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO EXTEND
A HUGE THANK YOU TO YOURSELF
BUT SHARE AND ALL THE MEMBERS
NOTABLY. SOMEONE MEMBERS
CARILLO FRIEDMAN AND NAZARIAN I
THANK YOU ESPECIALLY A
COMMITTEE STAFF- IN IN THE
ASSEMBLY ON THE SENATE TO SPEND
A LOT OF TIME IN THE LANGUAGE
CONTAINED IN AB S. B. ONE FIVE
ONE ESTABLISHING THE VENUE'S
GRANT PROGRAM WE'RE SO GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU'RE
LISTENING HUNDREDS OF VENUES
FOR OUR STATE- AND THEN ALL OF
YOUR DISTRICTS WHO SO BADLY
NEED THIS RELIEF AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL TO SEE THIS PROGRAM.
GET UP AND RUNNING SOON LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH CALLAS
BUT IT GET THE ROLLOUT OF THE
PROGRAM EFFICIENT AND-
IMPACTFUL AND THANK YOU AGAIN.
FOR HELPING TO SAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA STAGES. ONE SIXTY
THREE EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN TANG AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SPREAD GLAD
BILL TO WITH APEX GROUP ON
BEHALF OF CURE LEAF AND PERFECT
UNION TO VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
CANNABIS COMPANIES WE
UNFORTUNATELY AND BUT LIKE TO
VOICE OUR OPPOSE SOMEONE'S
POSITION AMENDED- POSING AS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB ONE FOUR
ONE. WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE
EQUITABLE SUPPORT FOR ALL
CANNABIS COMPANIES REGARDLESS
OF THE TYPE OF LICENSE AND
SHOULD HAVE EQUAL TIME LINES TO
TRANSITION FROM THE PROVISIONAL
TUNING A LICENSE WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT THE COMMITMENT MADE
BY SOMEBODY MEMBER WOULD TO
HAVE A CLEAN UP BILL AND BUT
ALSO LIKE AN ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WITH MISTER BRANDON
THIS **** AND HAVE A WONDERFUL
DAY THANK YOU. EXPLODERS LINE
FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE HELLO GOOD MORNING
MISS GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS NANCY
SWIFT AND I AM CHAIR OF THE
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS WERE SIXTEEN
CENTERS WITH TWENTY OFFICES
STRONG ACROSS THE STATE I ALSO
AM THE FOUNDER OF THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTER AT JEDI I UP IN
THE NORTHERN PARTOF THE STATE-
EXPERIENCING THE CURRENT LAVA
AND TENANT FIRES. FIRST I
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
AS A NETWORK FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURES PROACTIVE EFFORTS
IN UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORTING
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS OVER THE
LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND NOW
INTO THE FUTURE IT HAS BEEN
VERY SIGNIFICANT. WE ARE WHOLLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE COMMENTS OF
LAURIE AND CLAUDIA AND HEIDI
AND DAVID THE PREVIOUSLY AND
HAVE SUBMITTED AS A LETTER OF A
VERY DIVERSE GROUP OF SMALL
BUSINESS- DEVELOPERS- TO YOU ON
JUNE TWENTY NINTH- WHAT. AT
WERE WHOLLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
RECOMMENDATION RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS THAT DO NOT DILUTE
THE EFFECTIVENESS AND THE
ASSETS. THAT YOU HAVE BUILT
ALREADY WITH THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF PROVIDING
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING THE SEVEN
MILLION FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE-
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ALLOW THE
DREAM FUND TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
THRIVE. AND TO CONTINUE REMOTE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM FOR ANOTHER FIVE. AS
FAR. FOR THE PILOT SAID A FULL
FIVE YEARS OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AS A
REMINDER TO THE PARTICIPANTS ON
THE PHONE LINES TO- TO GO AHEAD
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
JORDAN LINDSEY WITH THE OUR
COMMUNITY WILL PULL THE
CALIFORNIA COUPLE
COLLABORATION. REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA GOOD INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AND JUST WANT
TO. EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE AND
OUR THANKS TO THE INCREDIBLE
WORK DONE BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE ALEJO- STAFF. IN REALLY
CREATING WHAT CAN BE A
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENT FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
THIS YEAR- WE ARE EXCITED TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
DEPARTMENT. AND ENACTING MANY
OF THESE- ACTIONS. AND AGAIN
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE FOR THE TREMENDOUS
WORK THAT WAS DONE. AND THERE'S
BEEN YEARS IN THE MAKING AND
MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN A PART OF
THISAND THEY KNOW. AND JUST-
AGAIN THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THIS
AMAZING INVESTMENT. AND LINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES EAST SHANTI HALF AT CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
SAID EACH COMING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA MICRO
BUSINESSES COMING NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM THE
SPENDING WILL GO A LONG WAY IN
HELPING THE UNDERSCORE
UNDERSERVED BUSINESSES AND
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE CITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AN LINE
SIXTY EXCUSE ME LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR OPEN
SIXTEEN. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I
LIKE THE BIG OPPORTUNITY ARE
ALLOWED TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK SENATOR BAFFOUR
PROJECTING IN THE FINAL MY NAME
IS THAT YOUR CRUISE AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CANNABIS
COMMERCE COUNCIL BLAH BEACH
WHERE WE FOCUS ON POLICY
ADVOCACY COMMITTEE
REDEVELOPMENT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TO PRVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
CONTRACT WITH THE APPLICANTS
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF LONG
BEACH. AND HOPEFULLY BEYOND. I
LIKE TO TAKE THE TIME TO
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS OF SUBJECT
WOULD BE LEADERS LIKE YOU TAKE.
QUICO SKI COULD KEEP ME IN THE
PARKS AND THREE FRANKLIN.
STREET STATED EARLIER AGENCIES
DO NOT NEED WEAPONS AND
ALLOWING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THAT
WILL JUST CREATE A LEGAL FAKE
WAR ON DRUGS. AND IT'S A MORE A
STEP IN THE FACE FOR WHAT THESE
LAST COUPLE YEARS A LOT OF TO
FOCUS ON WHICH IS EQUITY NOT
EQUALITY. EVEN THOUGH SUCH
EQUITY THE NEW TERM FOR MOST
INCLUDING. EQUITY WITHIN ELECT
LANGUAGE OF SB ONE FORTY ONE
WOULD ALLOW MORE TRANSPARENCY
WITHIN THE BILL. YEAH SUCH
EQUITY OPPORTUNITY THE NEXT.
OPPORTUNITY GIVE SUCH EQUITY
ENTREPRENEUR AND EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITY. I PROVISIONAL
LICENSING AT THE POINT OF
APPLICATION AND EXTEND IT FOR
THREE YEARS. BECAUSE SHOULD NOT
BE REQUIRED FOR ALL LICENSE
TYPES EXEMPT RETAIL DELIVERY
DISTRIBUTION AND NON. VOLATILE
MANUFACTURING. GREAT EXPEDITED
CHECKLIST CONDITIONS FORTY
CULTIVATION AND MOTEL
MANUFACTURING. ONE STATE
AGENCIES SO THEY CAN PROCESS
APPLICATIONS FASTER AND ANSWER
OUR CALLS IN PERSON AND
PROVIDE. NEEDED LIKE MOVING
INFORMATION THANK YOU FOR A LOT
MORE REPORT TO THE DIVISION.
ADD MISTER I CARE WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATE
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO MAKE
INTERESTED IN MAKING PUBLIC
COMMENTS. OKAY SEEING NONE WE
ARE TURNED.